a lot of people have credited you for  Andrew Tate choosing to remove all of  his content from social media really  break that down he was on this 17 year  old fortnite stream he was doing the  rounds he went to like Aiden Ross he  went to clicks his stream he's like  going up against like these like 20 year  old kids and just basically farming  Their audience of like dummies like all  these like 12 13 year olds were like oh  I love fortnite oh this Andrew take guy  he seems so cool he's got a Bugatti and  basically he was like getting all of  them involved and invested in this like  thing he called Hustler's University the  MLM scheme and I saw that and I was  pissed off about it I was like what are  you guys giving this guy free promo he  was doing that and then like Clay's  manager is a fan of mine and he'd like  hit me up on the DMS he was like bro you  want to come on the stream and I was  like yeah I want to do this I want to  talk to this [ __ ]